how have I made a difference today
who did you smile
and who did you call to find out if
they're feeling okay
what have you done
if you can answer those questions in
today then you are living life at its
most meaningful way you have given and
shared something of great value
I agree Supreme Court Justice Sonia
Sotomayor spoke to graduates of
Manhattan College last week she
underscored the huge impact a simple act
of kindness can have that's also the
theme of our series a more perfect union
where we aim to show you what unites us
as Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning Don Dahler shows
us a College Road Trip and how it's
changing lives Don good morning good
morning this is such a great program
it's a free ride sharing service with a
heart that aims to drive home the
concept of paying it forward while
rolling down the highway this is what
retirement looks like these days for 76
year old Paul getcha he's not slowing
down rather he's speeding up spending
much of his time along the open roads of
upstate New York the greatest joy that a
human person can experience is a joy
that comes from serving other people
getcha is behind the wheel of an
important initiative volunteering at
OnPoint for college a nonprofit aimed at
serving underprivileged college students
if I couldn't afford the gas of the car
couldn't do it but I can and therefore
I'm happy to do it the organization has
logged over four hundred and forty two
thousand miles shuttling low-income
college students from their hometowns to
campus and getcha is responsible for
over sixty thousand of those miles
enough for two trips around the globe
today get uses in Rochester New York
picking up rubies atomic a sophomore
business major at RIT and taking her
home to Syracuse okay do you remember
when you first got in the car with him
on that very first trip when I first met
mr. G I called mr. G cuz I can't
pronounce his last name I can't
pronounce realistic still confused about
what I was gonna do in the future how
long did it take you to get comfortable
with him I had some kind of click with
mr. G we immediately became friends and
I was really excited and curious to see
how he you know approached college so
mr. G yes you must like to drive I grew
up on a poor dairy farm if I hadn't had
an education I know pretty much where I
would be today that doesn't look pretty
and you know having had the college
opportunity I want to see as many young
adults get that opportunity ruby was
born in the country of Myanmar also
known as Burma and is the eldest of six
children she's the first in her family
to go to college what does it mean for
you personally to watch these students
over the years actually start to achieve
their goals that you talked about in the
cab of your car so long ago just pure
joy to see them succeed and what they
thought they wanted to do now my wife is
good she it's an uncommon connection and
despite the generational gap it's the
relationships made along the way that
keeps ketches going so your your job is
more than being a taxi driver Oh for
heaven sakes I said would you say so yes
I would certainly hope that I contribute
everything I can he's being the best
version of himself Oh
they called me that expression I love
that you know and be the best version of
yourself okay I like that that's a
pretty great version now you'd think
after wandering all over New York
ketches would be an expert navigator but
he says without his GPS like me he'd be
lost still he admits taking a long wing
long way home with his young friends
gives them more time to talk about
things and make lifelong friendships
60,000 miles 60,000 miles what a lovely
man done and I was wondering if he had a
family and then I heard him say my wife
yeah which shows he has his own life but
he clearly wants to just help others -
yeah well and think about he has 76
years of wisdom that he gets - and they
soak it up like a sponge these students
really benefit from this it's all about
connection in this world but the GPS do
the navigating yes older people have a
lot to contribute them there's a lot of
color size that a lot of college
students could use a ride very true
never forget that Thank You Don dinner
without the beard it was here yesterday
what happened on some important women
whom I really respect yes did the baby
I'd like - yesterday - yeah